you're known as a
systems thinker in martial arts but you
also
i think are willing to think outside the
rules of the game outside of the system
when you're thinking about strategies of
how to
you know solve the problem particular
problem of an opponent whether that's
jiu jitsu or in mixed martial arts
what's your process for doing that
for figuring out that puzzle i would say
i don't know if i have a specific
like a to b to c process for that sort
of thing um i try to do my best to uh
appreciate that i think a lot of the
thinking um or
maybe not all the things but a lot of
great thinking on
conflict on battle on war on martial
arts has been done already
not that we don't have to do any sort of
uh background investigation or
reassessing of these ideas or axioms
that have come down through
things like the book of five rings or
the art of war or
you know like colossal it's even
anything like that really
but is uh we're trying to understand
the the lessons of the past that i think
often times we we don't take with us
um problem solving we pay lip service
and like oh yeah yeah uh you know a
victorious fighter uh the great fighter
uh you know
he knows victory is there then he then
then he seeks battle everyone else is
looking for victory in battle yeah
moving on and that's why i'm gonna
double jab and throw my left hand
and uh i think a lot of times our
actions don't reflect our stated
belief structure and i think that
oftentimes you can tell
what i believe really or what my
fundamental operating system is
based on my actions whether i'm aware i
have an operating system internally
whether i'm aware of it or not or
certainly whether i'm fully aware of it
so i guess uh when it comes to
strategy i i try to think about how
things interact you mentioned
systems thinking and i try to do my best
to understand how systems exist but i
think that
systems have a fundamental strength and
a fundamental weakness
they work how they work and that's great
but they're
readable so if you are aware if i am
operating on a system
of which you're you're not really read
into then i think oftentimes i can seem
like
shockingly effective particularly if my
system preys on certain weaknesses
uh that that maybe you are you're given
to
but what happens when you've read the
same books that i have
i think that a lot of times that makes
me deeply predictable i think about
systems in jiu jitsu you know and uh
a lot of times people think that they're
doing jiu jitsu when in reality they are
doing an expression of it let's say i'll
use there's the marcelo garcia system
there is the uh henzo gracie current
enzo gray system there's the old gracie
baja one
there's a you know the gracie academy
classic crazy jiu jitsu there's the
art of jiu jitsu um you know kind of
optos approach and you know there's some
crossover between a lot of these
but uh oftentimes i think um you know
when it comes to
understanding how i'm making decisions
and how my opponent is making decisions
i have to appreciate whether or not
i'm an end user of something and i'll
use my my phone as an example
i was thinking of this the other day and
as an end user of my phone i can't i
have no idea what it does
you know like edward snowden comes up
and goes hey guys you realize your
phones are listening to you
i'm like really what yeah all right i
believe you
and then of course that that comes out
but uh to what extent
i have no idea um what is my phone
capable of i have no idea
i can mess with the font though i really
like blue screens not purple screens
so like as an end user i can change some
of the bells and whistles that have
nothing to do with the underlying source
code of it all or how it functions the
same way my car
i'm an end user of my car if i do this
with the steering wheel it goes if i
push on the gas it goes
um if i yeah i know how to fix it when
it's out of gas i know how to fix it
when it's out of oil
and i know how to fix it you know when
uh when a flat tire comes but
short of that or actually beyond that i
have nothing so i think that oftentimes
um you know i've been around in jiu
jitsu long enough to encounter like a
new wave of
of like good grapplers and it's very
very interesting sometimes how
they're running systems they don't
realize they're running like i'm like oh
yeah
i trained at marcelo garcia's academy
for a long time you know and a
big fan of marcellus was a student there
uh encountered a lot of the
the otto style jiu jitsu a number of
years ago uh
been you know a very very you know deep
into foot locking and leg attacks and
whatnot for a long long time
i understand your system better than you
do or i may and let's say you understand
my system better than i do that would be
a huge issue that was something that i
encountered a long time ago
trying to come up in jiu jitsu where i
was trying to utilize
systems that were
created by let's say half a mendez or
someone else and i'm basically trying to
do what you're doing i'm just not doing
as good of a version of it so not only
am i not doing it well but i'm entirely
predictable
and i think that that can be a big issue
so to come back i think of systems a lot
of times now in terms of you know
particularly like end user type of
systems like
an iphone is a really really fast way
for me to be able to do all sorts of
things
if you were to take it from me i
couldn't recreate any of that so you
want to be more the nsa
unless the end user exactly exactly that
way that way i'm listening i'm going to
be the annual
day of combat that's right we're
watching up but basically
you know it's uh i guess what i would
what i would come back and say is uh
if you understand how things interact on
a fundamental level and what type of
games exist and what type of
interactions is this
then you can transcend a lot of the the
systems
it's almost like a cook versus if i can
make certain things in the kitchen i can
but i am not a chef you could give me a
bunch of ingredients
and i could probably cook not well but a
couple of different things
but a master chef you know would be
aware of the implications of all of the
things that they're doing
you know extra time in the oven less
time in the oven putting this
you know flavoring or spice in you know
what you're doing with various things
and also they could make they could turn
all of these ingredients into chinese
food they could turn these ingredients
into italian food and they could turn
all these italian food ingredients
into chicken parmesan or it could turn
into lasagna but
they're not limited to a specific thing
because they have knowledge of how
food interacts how what it does to
create taste what it does create texture
so to come back let's take rock paper
scissors rock paper scissors is built on
the idea
of a couple different things actually
i'll tell you what can i you might
may ask a question yeah what's your
favorite dinosaur on the same on three
we'll go
one two three t-rex t-rex i'll meet soon
man this is we're gonna be best friends
so uh it's
okay uh if so what's the first question
when you say hey let's play rock paper
scissors it's like is it rock paper
scissors rock paper scissors shoot
and you're like rock paper scissors
shoot you're like okay because if we go
rock paper scissors shoot and i'm like
oh man i
i got lucky and i want imagine i won a
hundred times in a row
yeah i'd be luck it'd be luck if i was
honestly doing that
but now let's say for instance i go on
rock paper scissors and you go on shoot
rock paper scissors shoot
here comes the rock right if you lose
whose fault is it
it's yours this is built on a parody
thing where
we i don't get to pick second if i get
to pick
second it's like being able to
investigate your background before going
to meet you and then i'm like oh hi
oh i too love the new jersey you know
the new jersey nets which is a statement
that no one in their right mind would
ever make
when i was growing up so anyway you'd
have to have personal knowledge of
somebody
so anyway to come back let's you're if
if you understand
how games are structured
you can start to realize that there's
huge gaps and huge holes in a lot of the
the thinking behind all of it
you